sure you want to dive into this show
today John deep thoughts by dananddana
thank you John thank you let me ask you
the poll question then John is LeBron
and Paulie give the exact wording to
John bear if LeBron James were Foley it
would be pre peak foliage peak foliage
opacity police
I go peak foliage has he it doesn't feel
like anything's slipping here is he
getting better or just is he different
yeah I was going back and thinking of
all the great players of all time
what great player was better in his 15th
years and he was as an eighth ninth or
tenth year and he is yeah he truly is
better than he was seven or eight years
ago there's no question in my mind last
night was one of the best I've seen I've
seen guys get 4050 but the degree of
difficulty on these shots no man it was
unbelievable but you've seen guys get in
a zone and that's what they call it when
just everything is going right do you
remember seeing somebody who had a night
like that that you played against or it
was a teammate pretty much everybody I
guarded every night no yeah no i I've
seen guys get 50 i I mean I saw Kobe
Bryant I sha Shaquille O'Neal when guys
were unstoppable but I've never seen
anything like that that was hold the
ball for 20 seconds and have a guy all
up over you and just go one dribble one
way or the other and fade and almost hit
the rafters with the with the flight of
the ball and hit just incredible shots
it was it was remarkable the shots that
he made I have a knock on LeBron and
it's not fair to bring it up today but
I'm going to because it has to do with
last night he works too hard in the shot
clock to get a fadeaway 25 footer I get
it always it feels like that fadeaway 25
footer should be when somebody else is
trying to do something and then it's
last-ditch to ever get it to LeBron
he'll get a shot off it's almost like
that's by design I don't think it's
great strategy
you know you go to the next round or get
to the finals but it certainly worked
last night yeah you're right I mean he
holds the ball to literally three four
seconds and then makes one move but when
he's got it going like that he feels
like that's the only thing that's going
to work but they had a lot of things
working laughs he's for 128 I mean
Toronto was trying anything they had
mismatches on Kevin Love who got it
going and there's just no fear factor
for Cleveland of the Toronto Raptors
now it's Iran as a better team there's
no doubt about it but they have a
Cleveland complex do the Raptors and
it's a lot to do with LeBron J
but explain that though that you have
the best record home court advantage
you're great on offense great on defense
great home court and you got Drake
cursing and everybody I mean what are we
missing here a superstar who's won in
the NBA without superstars you go back
to 2004 Detroit that's maybe the only
argument you can make but they had guys
that were you know number one players on
their teams and Chauncey Billups and
Rashad Rasheed Wallace and Rip Hamilton
maybe not super superstars but they had
a pretty good collection but other than
that every team that's one has one of
the top 5 to 7 players in the game what
do you do Toronto doesn't but I have
said at the start of this series we're
gonna find out a whole lot about both of
these teams as they move forward we're
finding out that LeBron is still LeBron
but we're also finding out you know
Toronto could be imposters here do you
what do you do with this roster if let's
say they lose let's say they go down in
flames in 6 or 5 or whatever it is you
know as you move forward what are you
doing with this Toronto franchise with
this lineup major questions you're you
owe Ibaka 40 million over the next two
years he played 12 minutes last night by
the way
Oh for five from the field
Kyle Lowry is is on the decline an older
player he I believe he has 66 million
left in two years
what else are people gonna want I mean
he's got some good young town
then fleet is played very well the long
right port portal but really the only
thing you have is demar derozan and
that's your best player but that seems
to be the only guy that you would get
anything for so this this team is it a
real crossroads there's no doubt about
it I love how we keep trying to define
redefine LeBron James greatness here
because we always it always comes back
to square one and that is you know where
does he rank with Michael Jordan do you
think that will ever get to the point
where we know that he's not Michael
Jordan so that it feels like we don't
appreciate LeBron James because it
always comes to the bigger picture of
yeah but he's not he's not Michael all
right I don't think we I don't think we
appreciate LeBron I I really don't why
is that I mean I guess we're older so we
like older stuff right I mean that's
kind of what it is you know no but I
appreciate him look I I cover I you know
I was there to watch all those Jordan
championships but I tell people you're
just you don't see this with LeBron and
what he's doing you just don't it's so
rare to see this but I don't think that
we appreciate it I totally agree I don't
think he's gonna pass Michael Jordan
he's not going to win as many titles I
don't believe number one and that seems
to be what people like to make the
comparison well he hasn't won as many
titles which to me is a really bogus
argument look at the talent that LeBron
James has other than Miami for those
couple years and this guy could go to
the finals for eight straight years and
and I mean that's one guy like and you
could put him on any team in the east if
he was on Milwaukee would you say
they're the favorite to go to the finals
yes absolutely Indiana
absolutely you can maybe even go down to
Brooklyn calm down
but you remember we were in Cleveland
when that Cavs team played your brother
and the Spurs and we were going how are
they even here it's the it's got to be
arguably one of the top five worst teams
in modern basketball history to go to
the finals no question I think they
scored over 85 once in the series it was
it was hard
yes yeah that was the worst I thought
that was the worst finals team ever but
it was him leading the way and he was
what 22 years old at the time so yeah I
mean it's it's an cry like I said I
think he could go on any team in the
East and I certainly their playoff teams
maybe not championship teams but he gets
any team in this league in the playoffs
where regardless of where he goes Kobe
Bryant in his 15th season averaged 25
four assists and five rebounds LeBron in
his 15 season averaged 27 nine and eight
and-a-half rebounds while playing thirty
six point nine minutes he played all 82
games you know Kobe played all 82 games
in his 15th season there but you know I
always I think enthusiasm is the first
thing to leave you you know as an
athlete like you're just not as excited
in the obscene you know he's spent over
a million dollars on just you know a
trainer and working out and nutrition
and all of these things to have that
energy at his 15th season and play all
82 games now I question if that's gonna
come back and haunt him here if they get
to the next round or even to the finals
but you know those are remarkable
numbers there I thought he was done in
Indiana to be quite honest like they did
Game three or four and he was it was
just exhausted I mean he had nothing I
mean how about he goes 12 for 30 in Game
one here and then bounces back and goes
19 for 28 I mean it's really you're
right I mean there's got to be an
appreciation you might not like some of
the things that goes down off the court
and maybe it's social media or the
entourage or whatever but respect was
between the lines because it is it's
pretty unbelievable I know that you were
working at the time maybe you got to see
the second half with the Celtics in the
76ers I did what do you make of that
Brad Stevens like this guy is an
incredible coach there's a belief
between these guys and they got tough
rugged guys now Rozier Marcus smart
Markieff Morris I mean it our for these
guys are just dogs and they they they
don't give up 22
down yesterday yeah and they make a
furious run in that second quarter and
you know Marcus smart to me is the heart
and soul of that team and he brings
something to this group that they have a
great belief and I mean amazing that
they go up to oh I'm wondering though
with these injuries with Gordon Hayward
and Kyrie Irving if and you don't want
this but you got this and you got the
benefit of these younger kids getting
big minutes taking big shots big moments
here that this is one of those things
you extrapolate you go maybe next year
at this time you look at all the
experience they have and how deep that
bench is and that's when they're gonna
be a beast well right but also at the
same time don't you have to say Oh Jason
and Jalen by the way you got to back off
now because these two guys are here and
they're the ones gonna be taking the big
shots you know it's great that they get
this experience yes Jalen has taken a
major leap and Tatum if what Hayward was
there this year would never be playing
these type of minutes yeah
but now they played them they played a
role now they're gonna have to kind of
back off next year you can't have all
four of those guys can't be having the
basketball and shooting all the time
it's a good problem to have though John
don't you think you know I know I'm with
you but you know is Tatum gonna have the
same impact next year when Hayward's
back I mean I don't know well he might
get easier looks he might not get as
many looks but he'll get easier looks
potentially ya know I mean there look
there the team to beat as soon as LeBron
heads to LA it's it's it's Boston all
the way we are we batting a dinner on
that you say he's not I don't know okay
well I'm just guessing I don't truly
know anything I guess I can't if I said
I'll give you the Lakers and I get the
field for dinner well there's two places
he's either going there or Philly so
I'll give you Philly well give me give
me Cleveland in Philly and I'll give you
the Lakers for dinner bingo okay fair
enough
do you have are you going back to
Cleveland now four games game three yeah
looking forward to it all right well
then we'll check in with you if that's
oh
okay have you been to the rock little
home thing I stay next to it I have not
been in no no John go in there
really oh my god it's awesome but are
you a big music guy I'm a big Pearl Jam
guy that's about it
have you gone just have you met Eddie
yes you have well yeah
wait are you not allowed to talk about
it you said it like no no well actually
Brett and I are friends with Jeff Ament
the oh yes our it first and then we've
branched none at all you know who the
Prince got the horseshoe up his butt
he's everything championships and the
whole bit oh here we go here we go i
text John the other night and I said you
know hey bones is his brother I said boy
brother best looking better looking at
the Barry brothers and John goes what do
you mean by that and I said well he's
doing TV you're doing radio and then he
goes oh yeah I guess you're right
ray do you know what are you gonna do I
think because your brother has
Championships and he's got hair
evidently that's the case I think I'll
go with that
what would you rather have hair or a
ring ring oh you would
absolutely think it through never think
it through well known now you need hair
like when you were married it didn't
matter if you didn't have here I see it
the other way all right you're welcome
for me giving to you by the way I am now
salt on the Brahma [ __ ] or whatever the
heck is the name of that that was
classic so there's a lot time it's a lot
to see lot time that's what I thought of
that machine yeah the Machine Zoltar
they once long how much he liked himself
oh how good was he though he was so much
fun is who is Slaton in the NBA oh gosh
draymond would have to be on in the
conversation this dream on speak
third-person just dream on love dream on
no I'm just talking about it guys I love
them I think they're just the greatest
thing ever
yes
be in there I mean you could put a host
of guys in there I'm sure embiid oh god
yes perfect by the way there's some win
it I know Ben Simmons come on John
that's embarrassing last night that's
embarrassing
the Paracel that's tough does he get a
Hall Pass
well no in a bad game yeah gotta compete
Donovan Mitchell's playing pretty good
yeah but that's when somebody says oh
you know these guys were like I said I
only played a couple playoff games no
that's that's not how it works here you
know now all of a sudden we go back to
him being a rookie he's not a rookie
anymore you don't get a hometown here by
the way by the way if if you have a
rookie season that unfortunately you
can't play too bad for you you're not a
rookie the next year don't you know what
would you you don't think you still got
to play I don't care how many years
Markel Folds watches the NBA that
doesn't mean he's gonna be the Rookie of
the Year when he does play okay but I
think you I think you get more out of a
year of being with a of course I think
than you do playing in the SEC all right
I mean look I have no problem Donovan
Mitchell wins this none whatsoever
I think Simmons had a better year if you
want to do it where hey one's that
rookie and one's not that's fine I'm
okay with it
Yeah right hey thanks for joining us
I'll talk to you soon okay all right
that's John Barry for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]